[Music]
good evening everyone this is the
diehard group staying to the last
session of the day even during happy
hour Wow but I feel like we should be at
the at Google back during one of our
TGIF meetings we can all crack open a
drink and just sit here and chat so
anyhow thank you very much for joining
our session this evening my name is Joe
kava and I'm the vice president of data
centers so that means that I lead the
teams that design build and operate our
data centers globally and I really
appreciate your interest in this topic
today so I'm going to share with you a
little bit about what makes Google Data
Centers so unique so let's first start
by considering what do you need from
your data center all right sorry we're
going to go to plan B C is a good data
center guy I've always got a back-up
plan
anyhow so whether you're currently in
your own enterprise data center or
you're in a multi-tenant colocation
facility what you need is access to high
performance computing always available
around the world when you need it where
you need it that's exactly what you get
I know that so you know as I mentioned
you need access to high performance
computing available around the world in
highly available and secure data centers
well with Google cloud that's exactly
what you get you get it where when and
how you need it we've been leaders in
developing ultra high performance
reliable compute systems since the
earliest days at Google and using the
most innovative designs and no matter
how good our teams
and our systems perform we always feel
that we can do better so we have a
relentless focus on innovation and our
high performance computing is the result
of optimizing throughout the entire
stack nearly all of our infrastructure
is custom designed and purpose-built
for our own computing needs from our own
dedicated high voltage substations to
our customized electrical distribution
systems to our cooling systems designed
and built purposely just for our data
centers all working in conjunction and
optimized to provide the highest
performance and lowest total cost of
ownership computing anywhere you know
when I first joined Google 9 years ago I
was amazed at the extraordinary lengths
that the company went to to build our
own systems and of course as I learned
more it became obvious why we do that
but at the time I thought to myself I'm
like you know what makes us so unique
why don't we just buy servers like
everyone else well we go through all the
extraordinary effort because frankly
what we needed at our scale didn't exist
when we started in order to achieve the
performance efficiency and price targets
we had to build our own servers we had
to develop and create the hardware and
the software and the culture of
reliability to make Google successful
our servers don't include any
unnecessary components such as video
cards chipsets or peripheral connectors
which can introduce vulnerabilities our
production servers run a custom-designed
and stripped-down version of Linux
that's been hardened and our servers and
their OS are designed for the sole
purpose of powering Google services only
our server resources are provisioned
dynamically they're allocated and
to allow for us to be flexible in growth
and they can be represented when it's
needed to quickly respond to customer
demand and recently we've also
contributed our learning and our
experience with our custom 48 volts rack
systems we've contributed that design to
the Open Compute program so now open
compute program racks also work in
Google data centers and you know since
I've been at Google we fundamentally
redesigned our cooling systems about
every 12 to 18 months and along the way
we've pioneered and developed
advancements in water-based cooling
systems such as sea water cooling
recycled gray water cooling storm water
capture and reuse rainwater harvesting
industrial canal water use and thermal
energy storage and we've also designed
data centers that don't require any
water for the cooling at all instead
they're cooled with 100% outside fresh
air the point is is that there is no
one-size-fits-all model here all of our
data center designs are custom for that
specific region that specific location
to get the best efficiency we also
invest a lot in robotic innovation on
our data centers each of our data
centers has fully automated disk erase
environments this allows for faster
higher throughput more efficient and
better inventory management now of
course what
performance and innovation you need data
centers and locations that work for you
and at Google our numerous locations and
fiber network differentiates us from the
rest our IP network consists of our own
fibre public fibre and undersea cables
and this allows us to deliver highly
available and low latency services
across the globe
but it also means that we can respond
faster to demand efficiently scaling our
capacity for when you need it and where
you need it it's even been noted by
several industry publications that this
is clearly a standout for Google and of
course as you can imagine with the
explosive growth in public cloud
computing we've had some pretty
aggressive expansion going on ourselves
and of course our global network brings
our data centers close together and
closer to you we're available currently
in six regions and 18 zones with over a
hundred points of presence and our data
network is comprised of hundreds of
thousands of miles of fiber optic cable
to ensure every customer has a cloud
region near them Google cloud will add
several more regions in 2017 including
the ones that were announced just this
morning by oars so we now have new
regions available in the Netherlands
Canada and California we need to operate
our own data centers around the world to
keep our own products running 24 by 7
our data centers are part of a very
robust infrastructure that supports
Google scale and Google's global network
including our 4 owned undersea cables
just far more than any other cloud
provider has and our edge points of
presence where we connect Google's
network to the rest of the internet you
know via peering of course and having
those multiple points of presence across
the
Loeb provides strong redundancy so your
data is securely mirrored across storage
devices in multiple locations by
choosing Google Cloud you can build on
the same future-proofed infrastructure
that Google builds on the same
infrastructure that Google uses to
return billions of search results in
milliseconds the same infrastructure
that Google uses to serve over 1 billion
hours of YouTube a day the same
infrastructure that Google serves over 1
billion Gmail users every day and at the
core of our program really is our
commitment to availability you know I've
been doing this a very long time and
I've evaluated dozens if not hundreds of
public and private data centers all over
the world and I can tell you that
they're not all created equally so when
we say truly 7 by 24 we really mean it
our designs are fault tolerant and this
protects you against potential failures
and our critical infrastructure is
concurrently maintainable this means
that whenever something breaks or
maintenance is needed we don't have to
take down services to do that there's no
such thing as scheduled outages on
Google cloud this is invisible to you
and we're enable it enables us to do all
of this live so we design our data
centers with an eye towards the future
we build in hooks that allow us to take
advantage and upgrade our systems and
network with the latest platforms
developments but we also staff our data
centers 24/7 with our own team of
Googlers who have been intimately
designed from design or they've been
intimately involved from the design
through construction and commissioning
and through operations they're the best
in the brightest engineers and
operations professionals available
anywhere
but they all come from very diverse
backgrounds and they have one common
trait all of them their systems-level
thinkers you know many of them have come
from critical mission mission critical
environments like the Navy nuclear
submarine program where mistakes can be
catastrophic
they understand mission critical
operations further we've built site
teams at all of our data centers that
are comprised of the engineers
responsible for the design and
construction of the data center working
side-by-side with the operations teams
their experience and qualifications is
unmatched the majority of our staff hold
advanced degrees and professional
licensing they've been published in
technical papers and books and they hold
patents relevant to the industry and
together these integrated teams are
responsible for the capacity
commissioning and providing 7 by 24
operations this really gives us an
unparalleled level of end-to-end
ownership of our infrastructure you know
having Googlers operate our own data
centers is really key you see the norm
in the industry is for the design-build
contractor to hand over a set of
documents drawings and manuals and the
keys to the front door and wish the data
center operator good luck and all too
often the operations teams aren't even
employed by the owner of that data
center they're actually employed by the
lowest-cost
outsourced bidder so the level of
ownership is maybe not quite what we
believe it should be and if there's you
know one certainty in mission-critical
operations is that faults and errors are
going to happen in the middle of the
night typically on a weekend when no one
else is around to help and all your
suppliers are closed but that's not the
case at Google because it's us we're
there 24/7 all of our teams are working
around the clock to provide the most
available compute infrastructure but you
know equally as important as as the
operational excellence is
transparency and really we want to have
the continual learning that when a issue
does arise that we can expose that issue
and send it around the world to all of
our teams so that everyone can learn
from it you know we studied the root
cause of errors and issues in the
industry based on published data and on
the infrastructure side the industry
norm is that human error accounts for
the overwhelming majority of all
incidents
however because of our designs and
frankly because of our very highly
qualified people only a small fraction
of our issues are related to human
errors and of those none of them has
ever caused any downtime at our data
centers so in addition to high
performance innovation and availability
you want your data center to be
environmentally sustainable as well as
secure so first let me talk about
sustainability a little bit Google data
centers are the most efficient and
environmentally friendly in the world
for as long as I've been building and
operating data centers I've been an
advocate for efficiency and
sustainability running our business and
environmentally responsible way is
important to us and it's something that
we also know it's important to you takes
a tremendous amount of power to run at
our scale as a matter of fact last year
the total amount of energy consumed in
Google worldwide for all of our
operations was just almost equivalent to
the total amount of energy consumed by
the city of San Francisco in the same
year but we want to be really good
stewards to the environment even though
we are consuming a lot of power we want
to use renewable energy as much as
possible so this year we're very very
excited to announce that
in 2017 Google is going to reach 100%
renewable energy for all of our global
operations data centers and offices
combined this means that for the
calendar year in 2017 Google is directly
purchasing enough wind and solar
electricity to account for every unit of
electricity we consume globally this is
a huge milestone for us and it's frankly
the culmination of seven years of effort
from all of my colleagues across the
company so how did we get here we
started this journey back in 2010 when
we did our first wind deal with a wind
farm in Iowa
back then we were amongst the first
corporations to go out and buy renewable
energy directly we then started
expanding doing more deals globally and
moving more into solar along the way
also we now have 20 deals that are
equivalent to 2.6 gigawatts of renewable
energy and this has generated emissions
reductions that are equivalent to taking
1.2 million cars off the road and in
doing so this makes us the largest
corporate buyer of renewable energy in
the world and by a wide margin and
thanks in part to the work of renewable
energy tariffs and our Power Purchase
Agreements and the related efforts by
our peers in the industry the number of
corporate renewable energy deals is
soaring we've been committed to sistahs
to sustainability since the earliest
days of our data center program and
we've been carbon neutral for more than
10 years now and in addition we
accolades along the way awards and high
marks most recently Google achieved the
final grade of a in green pieces 2017
clicking clean report which benchmarked
the energy performance of the IT sector
and only three companies out of the 15
that they evaluated to achieve that a
grade so something we're very proud of
we're very
cited by the growth in renewable energy
and we're dedicated to increasing the
ability of customers to take control of
their energy supply but there is more
work to be done we continue to look for
new ways to help utility business models
become more customer centric so that
cost-effective renewable energy is
available to anyone who wants it and
finally security is of the utmost
importance and importance in our data
centers our infrastructure is protected
by more than 800 top experts in
information application and network
security Google's focused on security
and data protection is amongst our
primary design criteria our physical
security team or our physical security
systems feature a layered security model
including safeguards like
custom-designed electronic access cards
alarms vehicle access barriers perimeter
fencing metal detectors biometric
biometric authentication and our data
center floors are protected by laser
beam intrusion detection our data
centers are monitored 24/7 by high
resolution interior and exterior cameras
that can detect and track intruders
access logs activity records and camera
footage are available in case any
incident does occur and our data centers
are also routinely patrolled by very
experienced security guards who have
undergone rigorous background checks and
training and you know the closer you get
to the data center floor the more
rigorous the security systems get also
as a matter of fact to gain access to
the data center floor it's only
available through a secure corridor that
requires badge access biometric
authentication and passing through anti
tailgate devices and only approved
employees that have a specific role to
be on the data center floor ever set
foot there that means that less than 1%
of our employee
population ever set foot in one of our
own data centers we employ a very strict
end to end a chain of physical custody
for storage tracking everything from
cradle to grave from the first time a
hard disk goes into a machine until it's
verified cleaned and erased we know
everything about that media we know who
touches it when it was touched what it
was touched for and why was its next
expected action our information security
and physical security go hand in hand as
you know data is most vulnerable when
it's in in transit and for this reason
securing data in transit is our highest
priority at Google data traveling
between customers devices and our data
centers is encrypted using HTTPS TLS so
transport layer security and in fact
Google was the first major cloud
provider to enable TLS encryption and
this homogeneous environment is
maintained by proprietary software that
continually monitors the system's
binaries for any binary modification for
our teams to be successful they must
have advanced real-time visibility into
the status and functionality of our
infrastructure as you know to say that
Google is obsessed with data might be a
little bit of an understatement so our
teams build systems that allow us to
monitor everything we've built
world-class monitoring and control
systems for all functional areas from
the servers and storage and network to
the electrical distribution the
mechanical cooling systems and the
security systems we're monitoring all
aspects of performance and operations
from chip to chiller and I said mint
and energy efficiency is at the heart of
our sustainability program you know we
believe that the best energy saved is
the energy not consumed in the first
place that's why we pioneered hyper
efficient computing systems and data
centers and that's why our data centers
consume on average only half of the
energy of a typical enterprise data
center what makes us really stand out in
this regard is how we've applied machine
learning to drive energy efficiency even
further if you've been in the keynote
speeches over the last couple of days
you've heard how much emphasis Google
has been placing on our machine learning
programs well you can imagine our data
centers are very large and complex where
the electrical and mechanical control
systems are all working together to
deliver optimal performance but because
of the sheer number of interactions and
possible settings for all of these
systems it's impossible for you know us
mere mortals to visualize what the best
way to set up the data center controls
are for those specific operating
conditions and to do it in real time
however really it's fairly trivial for
the computers to crunch through all
these possible scenarios and find the
optimal settings so over the past couple
of years we've developed an algorithm
and we've trained it with billions of
data points from all of our data centers
all over the world we now use machine
learning models to help visualize this
data so the operations teams can set up
the data center electrical and cooling
plants for the most optimal efficient
performance on any given day it's also
used considering up to 19 independent
variables like the weather outside the
temperature the humidity the wind
direction the wind speed all of these
things go into how efficient a data
center runs but without a machine
learning model it's almost impossible
for the operations teams to to try and
adjust that real-time so in partnership
with our colleagues at deep mind our
data center team built models to
recognize and learn
from these patterns in the large amounts
of operational data that we collect
every day anyhow we just restoring it
and not really using it that well so now
this is you know over some trial and
error and perfecting the model the model
is now over ninety nine point six
percent accurate and predicting our PE
and PE is power usage effectiveness it's
a measure of data center efficiency and
it has helped us to identify up to forty
percent savings in the data center
cooling overhead this equates to an
overall fifteen fifteen percent
reduction in our PE which you know may
not seem like a lot but if you think
about the hundreds of megawatts of data
center capacity that we have online
every year that is equated to several
tens of millions of dollars in energy
savings per year but you might wonder
why why do I care why do I care if your
data centers are efficient well one of
the reasons why you care is because our
operating costs are directly related to
the efficiency of our data centers our
pricing on Google cloud is directly
related to our operating costs so the
more efficient we are internally the
more of that savings we can pass through
to you we can offer the most high
performance lowest cost public cloud
available and leverage
strengthen this machine-learning we've
succeeded in increasing the overall
efficiency of our data center fleet this
makes Google the data center you need
the one that you really can't afford to
be without high performance computing
available around the world secure
reliable where you need it when you need
it and how you need it
you